it's the magic of 360
welcome to the Graduate School of
Business we thought it would be nice for
you to see the campus where you would
come and participate in our program as
we walk here through Town Square
you see these buildings to my left and
to my right those are the buildings
where we hold our classes that's where
you'll be for two weeks learning about
how to be innovative marketers let's go
visit a classroom this is one of our
typical classrooms beautiful and
state-of-the-art coming on the beautiful
Schwab residential center also see our
signature palm trees here we go the
Schwab residential center the GSB is
known for having excellent food in its
executive education programs so here we
are this is where you the courtyard will
you'll be meeting your fellow
participants
and having three meals a day three
extremely nutritious highly caloric
meanest so part of the program also
includes guest lectures and evening
different startup entrepreneurs
sometimes different investors sometimes
professors and other departments in the
school that present some interesting
research have a meal in addition to
election the Romans said healthy mind
healthy body so here in our programs we
take care of both of your mind
obviously through our immersive work in
the classrooms but also of your body
with our meals and of course our gym hey
guys how's it going a beautiful library
is just up ahead
classrooms are to my left to my right
whoops
stay on the pass they don't like it here
when you step on the grass and off we go
to the athletic facilities
let's step inside of the Arriaga center
here's something else that I think is
cool a bouldering space rock climbing
[Music]
to my left is karate those who need to
get nervous energy out
[Music]
it's our 360 video for the Jane Dana
life here's co-director Bobby ship
working out
hey guys and here we are coming back
onto the GSB campus after our workout
ready for a day of classes intense
learning and a ton of marketing
innovation
[Music]